das ist das meer vor der küste wallis
ein meer aus plastik nicht an jedem tag
nur wenn die strömung ungünstig ist aber
macht das besser
ist das noch ein paradies strände im
müll
auch nicht jeden tag nur wenn die
strömung ungünstig ist aber macht das
besser nein sagen die schwestern isabel
und melanie nein zum plastikmüll sagen
sie laut und deutlich
bye bye plastik wächst plastiktüte so
haben sie ihre bewegung genannt der name
ist programm
heute heißt das eine schulklasse bekommt
nachhilfe in sachen umweltschutz
aufräumen am strand machen kinder nicht
gern
vielleicht müssen sie ja nur den sinn
sehen hier ist das so isabell und mila
team motivieren uns sie sind vorbilder
wir sammeln plastik weil es den strand
verschmutzt und das meer
isabell und melodie waren zehn und zwölf
als alles begann
sie hatten damals einfach die augen
aufgemacht sahen zu viel plastik zu viel
müll und verstanden das was geschehen
muss
der erste kick dann über die sozialen
medien
die beiden ersten likes kamen von
unseren eltern nach 24 stunden hatten
wir schon 6000 unterstützer da wussten
wir jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr
das wird was großes so viele menschen
wollten das selbe wie wir ein verbot von
plastiktüten auf bali
das ist bis dahin noch sechs jahre
dauern würde konnten die nicht an
in diesem sommer aber der große erfolg
ein weg plastik ist jetzt auf bali
verboten tüten strohhalme styropor das
gesetz ist in kraft die umsetzung
beginnt das haben isabel und mellat ihn
nicht allein geschafft aber ihr beitrag
ist offensichtlich immer wieder
kampagnen aktionen und politiker nerven
stimmung machen im besten sinne
das bild hat sich geändert erst haben
sie gesagt oh wie süß die beiden kinder
wie sie sich einsetzen
aber jetzt haben sie begriffen wir sind
stark und wir fühlen uns verantwortlich
wirklich etwas zu verändern und wir
haben auch an uns gearbeitet wir haben
verstanden dass wir ausdauer brauchen
man kann nicht nur träumen und reden wir
müssen was tun vorangehen wachsendes
umweltbewusstsein der umgang mit müll
das hat auch den staat und seine
behörden erreicht in indonesiens häfen
kommen schiffsladungen an aus europa
amerika australien an bord papier und
plastik ein geschäft für indonesische
recyclingunternehmen wenn das plastik
hochwertig und sauber ist aber das ist
längst nicht immer der fall
in der deklarierten ladung versteckt
findet der zoll zunehmend nicht
recycelbaren müll den die exportländer
illegal loswerden wollen wir werden
jetzt 547 container zurück in die
herkunftsländer schicken
wir haben darin gefährliche stoffe
gefunden batterien und verschmutztes
nicht recycling weges plastik das ist
illegal wir wollen das nicht wir
schicken das zurück
öffentlichkeitswirksam inszeniert die
jagd nach illegalen müll
aber es gibt immer jemanden der daran
verdient
so kommt auch verbotene abfalltonnen
weise ins land wird irgendwo entsorgt
abgeladen verbrannt verpestet die luft
fernab der plätze wo er mal entstanden
ist
auf dieser deponie bei jakarta landen
täglich 7000 tonnen müll das meiste
völlig legal aus der hauptstadt
was die einen wegwerfen ist für sie hier
lebensunterhalt die suche nach
verwertbaren wieder verkaufbaren
immer wieder steckt zwischen legalen
lkw-ladungen auch illegaler müll für
samba pa ti ist das sogar ein vorteil
alles was aus dem ausland kommt ist gut
fürs geschäft
importierter müll ist viel profitabler
den können wir direkt zum recycling
verkaufen der müll der hier aus der
umgebung kommt stinkt der aus dem
ausland ist viel sauberer
dafür bekommen wir mehr geld und nur
darum geht es irgendwie über die runden
kommen
das war hier für die ärmsten indonesiens
schon immer so aber trotzdem hat sich
vieles verändert
atis eltern waren noch bauer als ich
kind war waren das hier reisfelder aber
heute nur noch müll
es wird immer mehr überschwemmt unsere
häuser alles ist dreckig und stinkt und
das wasser aus dem brunnen können wir
nicht mehr trinken
ein leben in mein leben vom müll
für die ist das so und es wird zu
bleiben eine andere zukunft daran
arbeiten sie auf bali sauberer soll
design melodie und isabell haben ideen
pläne energie velati 18 jahre hat den
schulabschluss in der tasche
isabel 16 steht kurz davor studium
berufswunsch im moment wird alles dem
projekt untergeordnet ihre initiative
gegen plastikmüll ist inzwischen
weltbekannt sie sprechen auf kongressen
und konferenzen das macht selbstbewusst
die freddys future.de muss überall auf
der welt großartig aber wir haben mit
buy bei plastic tatsächlich ein neues
level erreicht was konkretes das sollte
auch andere ermutigen findet ein
machbares ziel und setzt es um da müssen
wir hin
wir dürfen uns nicht einreden verlieren
sonst werden wir wie das system das wir
alle nicht mehr wollen
wo geht die reise hin für zwei junge
frauen mit starkem willen für bali die
trauminsel für ganz indonesien
eigentlich für uns alle
es ist die frage dieser zeit